excited to have laura lenny join us here
on the rich eisen show it's a pleasure
for me because quite honestly she's the
nicest person i know
but laura thank you for joining us it is
my pleasure i can't believe that you're
here after all of this and
you are on the ozark set now
i'm filming in atlanta now yes i'm not
there right at this moment
but but yes i'm here filming what has
this been like for you working on this
show because
as i've said 17 times on the show
already you might be the nicest person i
know and you you play
one of the darkest characters possible
so how do you rationalize how do you go
to all these different places
oh well it's just fun i mean that's
that's the joy of a great character is
that you get to
you get to do all the sort of stuff that
that is far away from you
and you know to play someone who is so
reactive and so primally hooked into
um instinct you know is is just a lot of
fun
it's it's the sort of part you you hope
for and
you know i've known from from the first
day working on ozark it was just obvious
to me that i'd sort of landed in a very
special situation and
and because this is our last season
doing it we're all we're savoring every
second we have whether we're filming in
the land of covet or not
it seems as though working for jason
bateman and he's a terrible task master
so i'm sure that it
can't be fun to work with him at all no
terrible really just a
agony every second but he's you know the
thing about jason it's always wonderful
to watch someone who's
who has put so much time just over years
and decades into what they do
because their skill level just gets
higher and higher and higher and when
you watch someone sort of switch lanes
successfully to go from a type of
you know known for purely comedic stuff
and then to move into a whole other
realm
of not only dramatic acting but
producing at this level directing at
this level
you know it's it's an amazing thing to
witness and you're about to direct for
your first time
coming up i am are you excited
nervous how does that all fit in all
all of those things you know quite
frankly it's it's nothing that i
ever saw in the cards for me and but
i've had
people particularly jason really pushing
me to do it
and so i am excited i'm nervous i'm
scared it's a whole different way to
look at things but um
but i am looking forward to it we'll see
how i do
i think you're gonna do great susie
schuster laura linney here on the rich
eisen show laura you have every award in
the book
it's insane and you're up for yet
another golden globe but
uh i'm just curious like which what
means the most to you
out of every award you've won every
award i've won
which means the most i think i think i
won a swimming award in
camp in 1978
it's the thing that because i i was a
terrible swimmer
i was really bad and i really tried to
get better i mean i
really really tried and it really did
feel like
a reward for something that i went
through that was harrowing
and frightening and the other awards
that i've been lucky enough to either be
nominated for or get
you know it just comes out of doing what
i love to do
so i i've always i always have a little
sense of embarrassment and awkwardness
about
about the awards season even though i
know it's important and i love
every nomination award i have don't get
me wrong but
i you don't sort of feel like you really
deserve it you know i don't feel like i
did anything
outside of my you know anything heroic
i didn't do anything heroic but me being
like a little kid trying to learn how to
swim and being terrified and
working through that like i that that
award means something to me and it's in
my cabinet with like next to miami
[Laughter]
my swimming award i think we have to
know what stroke it was
it was well i had a very hard time the
crawl was just a disaster
it's the worst it's the worst just a
disaster and then when it all sort of
came together and
you know in some ways there's something
about learning i i've always found that
the arts
and sports and the military had there's
a through line through them all
because there is a if you know obviously
the physicality required
it's not just passion it's not just
expression of passion intellectually
it's also expression of passion
physically and when you sort of learn
how to work through something
physically it helps with every other
aspect of your life
it gives you a sense of of confidence
and
camaraderie particularly if you're doing
it with a group of people
um and i've always found that even
though
like in high school the the theater
geeks and the sports
people didn't really get along they sort
of stayed in separate corners
they had much more in common with each
other than they realized
we may have actually uncovered something
if you think about it and like in an
inside the actor's studio maybe it was
that swimming that propelled you to be
able to do all of these great characters
i'm not saying that i should take that
show over but i'm thinking we may have
hit on something here
laura well i think i think there is
something about just confronting
fear you know in in any aspect that does
when you actually confront it and you
figure out how to work through something
emotionally
spiritually physically intellectually
all at the same time when all of those
things are being um challenged
and you somehow put it together and have
those things work in concert
i think it's it it's a real evolution in
your development as a person
regardless of where you are um so i
think sports art
are are important in ways that people
don't always consider
um it makes sense to me and before we
talk about laura linney the sports fan
because i think a lot of you will be
surprised to actually hear about her
background with sports
one last question about ozark do you
ever watch it back yourself
i'm not good at that to be honest with
you i love seeing what everyone else is
doing but i can't stand watching myself
it's the worst i just it's just the
worst i hate hearing my voice i hate
watching myself i just don't
i just that part of it i'm not very good
at
um but i love watching everyone else so
i'll watch it and fast forward
i think i love watching you so i will
watch it for you
let's talk about it for me i will i will
and i have been and i'm i'm almost done
with season one
because i when do i get to watch tv with
three small kids at home so
it's it's few and far between but boy
you're dark
um well thank you you're welcome so
let's talk about your sports background
i think a lot of people might be
surprised that you came upon it very
early who introduced you to sports
my father my father and i used to watch
the knicks all the time
so it was you know dave de buscher and
her and earl the pearl and it was all of
those guys and it was
a v i saw my parents divorced when i was
young so i would go over and spend the
weekends with him and i think as a
you know as a single parent who was a
father to a young daughter he
he just didn't know what to do with me a
lot of the time so he taught me how to
play gin rummy and we would watch
we'd watch the neck um and he was not a
sportsy man but he played basketball
growing up in high school
so he followed the knicks and uh so that
was a big
that was a big thing a big bond between
the two of us and now
who watches what in your house now with
a husband yourself and with an
eight-year-old is he eight or is he
seven years old he's seven
so i have a husband from chicago so the
bulls are very much
uh at our table um
so we we'd um and the bears sorry the
bears the bears are at our table all the
time
and um my seven-year-old is now obsessed
with the nfl
and is an enormous khalil mack fan okay
so every time khalil mack
sort of you know throws his power around
my son is doing a
a major dance of victory um
so there's lots of bear stuff and then
and then my son also loves uh premier
league soccer
so we watched liverpool and you know
he goes back and forth between watching
premier league soccer highlights
and curious george which by the way
that's the perfect combination
don't you think yeah i think so i'm
proud of that
you should and also you know you know
how some some kids had
you know when i was growing you know you
decades ago farrah fawcett was on the
wall
and of the poster my son has alex morgan
like alex morgan is it alex morgan
is his first love and uh he follows the
women's
soccer team as well i had terry o'reilly
i had a bruins player on my wall and i
also had michael
jackson i had the larry bird magic
johnson back to back what did you have
on your way
mark spitz oh yeah well why not i had
that huge that long
like life-sized poster of mark spitz
with all the medals
and watching the olympics was such a big
deal
i mean i still love i crave the memory
of
jim mckay's voice i get that i get that
you know just like it's a christian
memory for me like
like rolling around on the shag
carpeting listening to jim mckay talk
about the olympics i just
all of that i just love it and i'm still
uh an olympics
um fanatic like i cleared the schedule
what are your favorite
events to watch for the olympics and are
you a winter or summer
kind of girl both i'm very much both i
love watching skiing i love watching
alpine skiing
you know and it varies every year i sort
of learn
something more about you know another
another sport you know sometimes i love
i also love hockey
i love watching hockey um i love the
sort of
the finesse and the brutality combined
of hockey
um so i you know i
i love watching sports and when you
learn about sports
also it just you know just
all the obvious stuff the strategy of it
the emotion of it uh how do you combine
the two
um you know instinct versus versus
execution and all of that i find it um
i find it really interesting and i love
watching an athlete get better
over time if they're giving up if
they're given the opportunity to do that
that's the best part of sports to me i
mean that's why i got into it i love the
story of these athletes developing where
they came from where they were going and
how they got better
yeah it's the i mean that's the part
that relates to acting i would imagine
that's the human story that makes you
interested
yes absolutely and development of skill
over time
and what people have where their
weaknesses are where their
strengths are how how that can flip-flop
over time
um you know i the psychology of sports
is fascinating to me
um you know i find it i find it really
inspirational
so in other words we have to get
together with a lean kishishi and your
manager and we have to think of a
a way to develop a movie that i can take
something from the sideline experience
we develop it it gets really dark but
actually late at the same time we're
gonna
there's gonna be a movie that comes out
of this conversation on the rich eyes
and show their house
and you know slap shot is my favorite
movie of all time
you're kidding if i could have slap shot
on
i've watched slap shot more than any
other movie ever made
i would watch keep going i'm sorry no no
no it's just i just think it's one of
the best films
just love it and i would watch love
actually
if that's my total remote drop oh god
that brother
the brother the brother the brother you
just had to stop answering the phone so
much
i know but when you feel like someone's
gonna off themself if you don't answer
the phone
it's a real headache you know it's a
real headache yeah it's a little
inconvenient
before i let you go back to the set and
again thank you for taking the time to
come on anything that you can any kind
of nuggets you can
proffer for us first season for this
last season
nope well that went well
i'm so glad i asked that but you know i
had to try because not a
thing i'm not giving you nothing that's
the worst
this is some interview this is some
interview
i hope you win dark underneath well i
mean
that's the thing that's what makes you
fascinating
you
you know i'm a little bit of this a
little bit of that i i hear you you're a
little bit of this and a little bit of
that and a lot of awesome
good luck i hope that you continue to
put together this gorgeous collection of
trophies on sunday night we are all
watching
this whole set is obsessed with ozark so
i want you to know i had to
i was cramming him in there and rich was
dying to get you uh
here to talk to you so hopefully you'll
be coming back with uh the rest of the
awards season as they come in but
thank you for making the time and go
back and say hi to bateman for me will
you tell them i said you know of course
i will yeah
casual name drop on the rich eisen show
laura thank you i hope to see you soon
same here thanks so much have fun it's
my pleasure
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here